la idea es como resultado de todo un
proceso de un camino personal también
como artista aquí en la compañía en
ordino y como inmigrante también te hace
preguntarte un poco en un momento de tu
vida sobre sobre quién realmente eres
sobre tu identidad sobre tus orígenes y
por qué estás aquí que te trajo a canadá
entonces ahí me di cuenta que también es
cierto que todos vamos también como
escapando de algo y afortunadamente mi
historia no es tan trágica como puede
ser de algunos otros hermanos hermanos
que también emigran también había
descubres que había bueno yo descubrí
que había algo que había como un dolor
también y comprendí que también era él
me escape de la vergüenza que mi familia
sentía de sus propios orígenes durante
toda esta historia familiar de parte de
materna entonces me di cuenta que tenía
mucha rabia también por eso entonces
surgió también que la vida te va
poniendo las señales y los pasos a
seguir en algún momento dado en uno de
los proyectos de mediación cultural
estando en también como en en contacto
con mujeres que adecuadas que donde
hicimos ceremonias él nos acercamos a
través de la ceremonia de todo el mundo
de forma natural llevaban las fotos de
su de su familia
de aquellos que ya partieron me di
cuenta que ya no tenía ningún lazo
ninguna imagen y nada de mis abuelos ahí
como me comencé a como como decimos a
cachar muchas cosas del por qué por qué
estaba yo aquí cuál era ese enojo que
tenía guardado y en fin fue todo un
proceso que a través de la danza y el
teatro fui como descubriendo a partir de
ese como retrato familiar me di cuenta
que en el momento de honorarios
leonora a mi abuelo mi abuelo de origen
agua que había estado como allí siempre
escondido lo que recuerdo de él es que
casi no hablaba la abuela y mi propia
mamá
mis tías y toda la familia en general
esconden se avergonzaban de eso no ellos
siempre sino nosotros somos gente bien
educada
como si el otro no fuera bien y no
fueras educado y entonces yo creo que es
también parte de los tiempos se hablan
de una reconciliación y creo que también
desde el fondo de mi corazón es como
es sacar pagar esa deuda que tenemos con
nosotros mismos y con los pueblos
indígenas
a
[Música]
nunca más
anuncio
y mohamed
[Música]